je voulais vous dire merci parce que
j'aimerais que avant qu'on ait encore 25
minutes d'émission même plus d'ailleurs
30 minutes d'émissions même 40 minutes
d'émission ma 35 minutes les chéris je
voulais vous dire merci déjà pour cette
année qui a été incroyable merci à vous
merci d'avoir été aussi nombreux je te
remercie aussi toutes les équipes bien
entendu de production chez remercier
tout à l'heure entendu alors je peux pas
tousseriter bien entendu mais voilà vous
savez ce que si je commence à citer
quelqu'un je suis mort donc toutes les
équipes de maquillage coiffure on l'a vu
tout à l'heure toutes les Chéries voilà
que j'embrasse fort bien sûr qu'ils font
un travail magnifique parce que je peux
vous dire que quand on arrive à 18h on
est vraiment dégueulasse
qui sont là et qui se marre avec nous
c'est vraiment une vraie famille et
vraiment on s'éclate avec le j'aurais
marqué tous les remercier toutes les
personnes qui sont sur ce plateau
[Musique]
bien entendu tout le monde c'est parce
que tout le monde Alex tout ça ils le
savent toutes les personnes de la
production voilà qui sont avec moi bien
entendu dash2o je le cite pas tous parce
que voilà forcément c'est c'est il y a
nombreuses nombreuses nombreuses
personnes kakoumbé et ses équipes et
Théo et ses équipes bien entendu Loïc
Lionel voilà ça va voilà toutes les
équipes d'agents toutes les personnes
âgées voilà qui travaille sur les
missions pH qui est formidable aussi
bien sûr il y a Diana il y a tout le
monde je peux pas citer tout le monde
bien entendu mais vous le savez Max qui
est formidable aussi voilà et voilà donc
je voulais vous dire merci à eux ils ont
fait un travail exceptionnel et merci à
Lionel Stan également le DG qui tient ça
d'une main de maître et Sébastien Bardot
et Loïc bien entendu juste les chéris je
vous remercie aussi la chaîne parce que
cette année encore une fois Cédric merci
à eux merci à Franck Appietto merci bien
entendu à Gérald Brice viré Alexandre
Israël mon Vincent Pujol bien sûr et
tout Pauline charme bien sûr Samira tout
le monde a tous ceux qui sont régis qui
viennent tous les soirs je voulais dire
pas la peine d'applaudir à chaque fois
sinon on est là jusqu'à demain c'est
rien de les applaudir les gens s'en
foutent les ne les connaissent pas donc
voilà donc non voilà donc je voulais
dire merci à vous tous voilà je vous
remercie également au Maxime Saada le
président du groupe qui est toujours à
mes côtés et toujours là pour me
soutenir je vous remercie aussi mes deux
amis Yannick et Vincent voilà qui font
que cette émission existe et merci à eux
de nous laisser une telle liberté merci
et vous savez comme je vous aime les
Chéries je voudrais aussi vous dire vous
le savez c'est passé énormément de
choses dans l'émission cette année et
c'est vrai que on le voit autour de
cette émission il y a deux poids de
mesure c'est à dire que nous on peut
prendre des amandes extrêmement
violentes alors que d'autres font
parfois la même chose et c'est vrai
qu'ils ne se passent rien je vous le dis
voilà encore vous allez voir voilà sur
des marques on a encore été retoqué là
par la recommande alors qu'il y a plein
d'autres émissions où il faut passer des
bars on voit des mecs avec des logos et
des crocodiles des trucs jamais rien et
c'est vrai que il y a une volonté en
tout cas de faire mal à Touche pas à mon
poste tu auras toujours cette même
volonté à la rentrée sachez-le vous le
savez on n'a pas la presse avec nous on
n'a pas les institutions avec nous on a
personne avec nous mais c'est surtout
parce que on a une liberté incroyable et
que ça dérange énormément et sachez que
TPMP sera encore là l'année prochaine
tout ça bien sûr en direct que TPMP sera
encore là que TPMP est encore là pour
trois ans minimum puisque j'ai encore
trois ans de contrat avec C8 les Chéries
donc je vous l'ai dit à tous ceux qui
essaient de tuer touchent pas mon poste
que ce soit des journalistes qui
essaient de faire des choses un petit
peu limite sur nous des institutions qui
essaient de nous mettre énormément de
bâtons dans les roues sachez qu'on sera
là et qu'on continuera à dénoncer ce qui
se passe il y a dénoncer des choses
inadmissibles d'ailleurs il y aura une
nouvelle séquence l'année prochaine qui
s'appellera on marche sur la tête pour
dénoncer tout ce qui se passe et bien
entendu on essaiera encore une fois de
faire avancer les choses c'est dingue
parce que tous ces donneurs de leçons
où tous ces gens qui sont un petit peu
contre nous sont toujours là pour dire
quand il y a des problèmes et moi je ne
vois pas de problème puisque c'est ici
une émission il y a la plus grosse
liberté d'expression je vous le dis il y
a pas une autre émission il y a une
telle liberté d'expression et ils sont
jamais là pour dire tout ce qu'on a fait
avancer dans l'année sachez qu'il y a
énormément de problèmes qui ont été pris
en charge par le gouvernement notamment
grâce à la mise en lumière dans tes PMP
beaucoup de choses ont bougé grâce à la
lumière dans TPMP beaucoup de gens se
sont sortis de situation inextricable
grâce à TPMP alors bien entendu les
autres journalistes ne reprennent jamais
quand ils prennent nos infos nous si
jamais mais ça je vous dis on s'en fout
total aujourd'hui tfmi n'a jamais été
aussi puissant sachez-le et si TPMP
faisait 50000 téléspectateurs il me
dérangeraient pas autant forcément on a
essayé ça fait maintenant 12 ans qu'on
essaie de tuer l'émission l'émission n'a
jamais été aussi forte et aussi
puissante donc merci à vous
et
merci à vous de ne pas écouter bien
entendu tous ces donneurs de leçons qui
nous disent qu'il faut écouter ce qu'il
faut manger à quelle heure il faut se
coucher
ce qu'il faut écouter comme musique pour
qui faut voter nous ici comme je l'ai
dit on accepte tout le monde on essaie
de faire parler tout le monde on
continuer à le faire et toutes les idées
sont les bienvenues à partir du moment
où il y a une contradiction comme l'a
dit Hugo tout à l'heure il y a toujours
une contradiction dans cette émission on
nous a reproché un tas de choses bien
entendu un moment on était une émission
promo Macron après on est devenu une
émission promet longchon après on était
une émission pro Zemmour après on était
une émission pro très à droite après on
était une émission
qui qui était inébition voilà qui était
qui qui était bien sûr trop proche des
musulmans ma propre et ça moi un moment
on m'a dit oui Cyril il défend trop les
musulmans j'étais fonky je veux après on
va dire ah bah non finalement non c'est
une émission on défend trop l'extrême
droite donc les mecs comprennent rien
dès qu'il y a un sujet dès qu'on habite
quelqu'un il tourne ils comprennent rien
à l'émission ils voient trois extraits
et ils sont leur idée sachez qu'ici il
n'y aura jamais de racisme
d'antisémitisme de xénophobie
d'homophobie dans l'émission sinon bien
entendu les chroniqueurs ne seraient pas
là et je pense que il y a beaucoup
beaucoup plus grave dans les autres
émissions on n'est pas là pour dénoncer
qu'ici ou c'est une émission je vous le
dis ou vraiment toutes les idées sont
les bienvenues et nous on essaie
d'écouter tout le monde alors oui on a
invité des gens d'extrême gauche un
moment c'est vrai qu'on invitait
beaucoup de gens d'extrême gauche voilà
après on est invité des gens d'extrême
droite on a évité des gens de droite
donc on a invité des gens du milieu au
moment c'est vrai qu'on a beaucoup
invité aussi des gens qui étaient issus
du gouvernement qui ont lors du vaccin
c'était bien normal
sachez qu'ici on a conquis que vous nous
apportez aussi sur les réseaux tous les
mots que vous nous donnez que vous nous
écrivez et bien sûr dans la rue moi à
chaque fois je vous dis c'est incroyable
les gens me remercient pour l'émission
et les vrais téléspectateurs les gens
qui nous regardent et les gens qui nous
aiment qui sont de plus en plus nombreux
puisqu'on a fait nos saisons records
savent ce qu'est l'émission où va
l'émission et ce que fait l'émission
enfin ce qu'elle essaie de faire pour la
société au quotidien donc merci à vous
et c'est vrai que cette émission je vous
dis moi je suis fier d'y être parce que
c'est vrai que c'est je pense et je vous
dis juste ce matin un énorme responsable
de télévision qui a fait des études je
peux pas dire que c'est et qui m'a dit
c'est fou Siri on a fait une étude sur
les animateurs tu écrases tout
en notoriété tu es loin devant tous les
autres et c'est grâce à ces 8 c'est
grâce à vous ils m'ont dit c'est
incroyable ils m'ont dit c'est en
notoriété voilà il y avait même même les
plus connus de TF1 sont loin derrière
toi en termes de notoriété et donc ça
prouve la puissance de l'émission et
c'est grâce à vous donc c'est incroyable
ce qui se passe je vous le dis et on est
sur C8 on est pas sur une chaîne
indienne et c'est vrai qu'aujourd'hui la
puissance de TPMP je le dis TPMP et
aujourd'hui quand tu cumules l'audience
les réseaux sociaux tout ce qui se passe
autour c'est l'émission la plus
puissante du PAF donc forcément je le
dis et je sais personne me contredira
c'est l'émission la plus puissante du
PAF quand vous passez une fois dans TPMP
vous demandez à n'importe qui même tous
les politiques qui sont nus on dit Cyril
c'est incroyable j'ai fait des 50
émissions avant de venir ici je suis
venu ici la seule émission dont on parle
c'est Touche pas à mon poste donc c'est
vrai que c'est l'émission la plus
puissante donc c'est grâce à vous les
chéris c'est grâce à vous ici c'est
grâce au public et c'est surtout pour ça
que TPMP bien sûr agace forcément il y a
eu des moments chauds dans l'émission
notamment avec le député sachez-le moi
je serai toujours comme ça je ne
changerai jamais voilà ceux qui veulent
que je change il faut qu'ils changent
des missions voilà parce que je ne
changerai jamais je dirais toujours ce
que je pense et je serai toujours
naturel je suis à l'antenne comme je
suis dans la vie sachez-le quand je suis
énervé vous le voyez quand je suis une
bonne humeur c'est la plupart du temps
vous le voyez aussi mais c'est vrai que
voilà l'émission C'est une émission
comme on dit d'humeur et on n'a jamais
eu une telle émission d'humeur à la
télévision et sachez que jamais un accès
en télévision n'a été
aussi
long puisque c'est vrai que c'est la
première fois qu'un animateur fait 12
ans bateau 13 de quotidienne ça n'est
jamais arrivé et c'est grâce à vous et
je voulais vous dire je suis encore pour
longtemps et je continuerai à m'amuser
ici et c'est vrai que je m'amuse
vraiment tous les soirs et tous les
soirs je me dis j'ai envie de leur
montrer ce qu'on a préparé j'ai envie de
montrer les témoins j'ai envie de
d'écouter les témoins qui sont là et de
faire avancer les choses et ça je suis
en essaie de nous mettre énormément de
bâtons dans les roues il y a eu des
insultes incroyables notamment sur
France Inter même je vois sofiara Mach à
chaque fois qu'il y a un truc à twitch
sur nous sophiara m'a elle n'est connu
que par le prisme de TPMP car le prisme
de Cyril Hanouna si elle peut vivre dans
mon ombre encore longtemps ça me fera
extrêmement plaisir et si je peux
continuer à faire vivre des journalistes
qui peuvent vivre dans mon ombre bien
entendu ça me fera extrêmement plaisir
et sachez que quand je serai cet été en
train de me remettre la crème à bronzer
je pense réellement voilà merci
merci
à eux de me faire vivre